one of the biggest problems I run into
making videos about symbolism is that on
almost every single video I will have a
series of comments criticizing me being
frustrated in me because they think that
I am somehow saying that either the
resurrection or whatever event I'm
talking about for example the videos I
made about Alex Jones people are
criticizing me saying that I am
describing what they're saying or the
event or the story as just a metaphor in
the sense that it is something which
isn't related to reality or is it
related to events and so hopefully this
video will be the final nail in this
coffin because I keep coming back to it
and everybody will understand that when
I talk about symbolism I also think and
it's also important to understand that
symbolism happens
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
for those who follow me carefully I
would say most people by now understand
that when I talk about symbolism I am
NOT talking about the notion of metaphor
or the I'd like you would say you know
the the wind was cold you know like my
heart in winter or whatever some kind of
of poetic metaphor to describe something
to give it feeling or to give it or even
a kind of simple metaphor in the sense
you know of let's say the pilgrims
progress where this image means
something else in the world when I talk
about symbolism I that is not what I'm
talking about what I am talking about is
the notion that underneath our stories
underneath images underneath also the
way we experience the world there are
patterns and that those patterns are
really the way the patterns of how
reality lays itself out so when I'm
talking about symbolism I am NOT
suggesting that the events that are
being referred to or the things that are
being spoken about didn't happen
sometimes they didn't happen sometimes
they did happen the important aspect
that I'm trying to point to is eat
whether or not we're telling the story
whether it's a fictional story or it's
actually a story of something that
happened an important thing that
happened especially those the structure
by which we even recognize that it's a
story the structure by which we even
recognize that it's something that we
need to pay attention to that that
structure is symbolic that is a symbolic
structure in a story you have the
beginning and moving towards a purpose
moving towards an end in an image you
have a frame which delimits it from the
rest of everything else all those things
or would bring reality together in us
for it for us to be able to see that
it's actually something something to pay
attention to and so this is really the
biggest break that everybody needs to
make in their thinking because when I
talk about the structure of how
something is described I am
neither I am NOT saying that it didn't
happen nor sometimes am I saying that
did happen I'm only trying to point at
how the manner in which the thing is
described is is a symbolic structure
many times these relate to actual events
that happened in the world why because
what I'm trying to show you is that the
the nature the main way in which reality
lays itself out is necessarily symbolic
the way that you perceive things in the
world is symbolic in the sense that
there's too much in the world and we
have to condense that information into
something that is meaningful it is
something that is a pattern okay and so
whether it is how you will you know talk
about your child's birthday party
whether it is whether it's about you
know the Bible story or a you know or a
Marvel movie within though all those
stories there is a symbolism a pattern
by which we recognize the meaning in it
okay now there are certain stories there
are certain texts which are more
symbolic in the sense that they seem to
condense in a more pristine manner these
patterns and they show them to us in a
manner which is clear because in Matt
you can imagine let's say the world
manifesting itself through different
patterns we have all these patterns we
have seasons we have let's say just in
terms of time we have seasons we have
years we have months we have weeks we
have days all these are cyclical
patterns that repeat themselves now
there is a mess there's a little bit of
messiness to these patterns that is the
seasons aren't always the same there are
four seasons but they don't always
always last the same length
sometimes one season is more intense
than the other you know but the pattern
of the season as we pull back and we
look at the seasons we can recognize
let's say the the pattern of seasons in
the West Frank we just we've cut it into
four there are four seasons which which
also relate to the the solstices and the
equinoxes of course none of this works
perfectly like a like an actual clock
we can still see within it through the
diversity we can see the pattern and
that's how all stories all patterns
manifest themselves there's a noisy
aspect to it there's a noisy aspect to
it but then within that noise
we are nonetheless able and not only
able but inevitably we will see the
pattern and so there are stories which
are more symbolic in the sense that they
tend to show us the pattern in a
stronger sense so when for example I
talked about how Alex Jones refers to
certain conspiracies talks about psychic
vampires talked about interdimensional
beings talks about you know of course he
is talking about actual events whether
or not those events are factually true
honestly I don't know but he's obviously
talking about events in the world but he
is describing them in a manner which is
which is extremely symbolic now when it
comes for example to the Bible this is
the biggest criticism that I've had is
that people somehow think that I don't
believe that the Bible is describing
event and and I will say it here and I
will say it as loud as you want to hear
it I think that every thing in the Bible
is describing events the the the idea
that ancient people were sitting around
and making up stories you know in order
to I don't know in order to fool other
people I don't know what I don't think
that that's just not how the world works
the the Bible is describing events and
not only the Bible but also all so many
ancient stories whether it's the Iliad
whether it's the you know the Odyssey
whether it's even even mythological
stories are describing events that
happened in the world they aren't just
pulling these out of there they're based
on traditions of things that people have
described as events in the world now
sometimes those events are not
necessarily as manifest as we would want
them to be especially when they talk
mythological stories when we're talking
about gods that are not in the world but
nonetheless they are talking about
events to a certain extent and when it
comes to the Bible in the Bible it is
very important that the the that the
symbolic aspect or the pattern aspect is
related to an event aspect this is very
important in the story of Israel the
story of Christ it is it is absolutely
important that those two are related to
each other but the question is the
question is how is it that we tell the
story now there is something which
happens I told you a little bit about
how the world tends to manifest itself
in a noisy manner and so there's a
pattern but there's also a noise there's
an order to any event but there's also a
chaotic fringe or a chaotic aspect to
that event and so when you describe the
event sometimes what happens and I'll
show you I'll give you a few examples of
that in the Bible and in Christianity
itself sometimes what happens is that
the noisiness of the event tends to be
tends to snap back to the pattern we see
that for example even in the the times
when you know an important character
accumulates legends around them now one
of the things you can do when you see
that legends have accumulated around a a
character is to say something like oh
all this is legendary all this is just
you know made-up you know that we need
to we need to sift through that in order
to see the real person the real
historical you know person and you see
that in for example in the historical
Jesus there's Jesus Seminar and all that
kind of in my opinion nonsense I don't
think that that's the right way to see
it when legends accumulate around a
figure with the the most important
aspect to ask ourselves is why are their
legends accumulating around that
specific person
maybe it's because that person is worth
paying attention to
maybe those summer
those legends that have accumulated
around that person are there to show you
something very specific about that
person now of course sometimes the
legends become extremely fantastical an
example of course is in the in the story
of Alexander the Great
the legends become extremely fantastical
now it doesn't mean that we have to
believe in the factual 'ti of all those
fantastical event factuality in the
sense of let's say kind of historical
facts the way we understand it today but
nonetheless those legends still describe
events to a certain extent and it's
important to understand the way that
they do and also the way that some of
those legends can point us towards the
character that the story is talking
about now in the in the Bible especially
in the story of Christ there there is an
importance in staying close to the
figure of Christ in the way that the
story's told and in the way that the way
that the Church Fathers have seen the
traditions how they were passed to us
there's a there's an importance in
staying close to the figure because
Christ himself is seen as the ultimate
let's say joining together of meaning
and events it is he is really this kind
of place where everything comes together
and so in his person there is it there
is a tendency to want to stay close but
to be honest as as an Orthodox Christian
I am I don't have a problem with looking
at some of the more legendary aspects of
the story and and even legends that came
later or traditions that came later that
appeared later in the church and seeing
them as important ways to understand the
the figure of Christ and what Christ
brought brought to the world now the man
the way in which stories tend to let's
call it compress maybe is the best way
to say it there tends to be a symbolic
compression where the noisiness of
reality will snap
back to the pattern so I can give you I
can give you a few examples one example
which is from the Bible itself is there
was in the time of Christ a tradition
which is not in the Old Testament but
was a tradition which was seen with
authority that before the Messiah would
come Elijah that Elijah would come and
manifest himself before the Messiah now
I'm not going to go into the actual
meaning of that pattern but you can see
it as a pattern that someone perceived
the pattern that before the Messiah
comes Elijah and that is the pattern of
how Messiah manifests himself how Christ
manifests himself in the world and so um
we can I'll go into the meaning of that
maybe on in some other video but let's
look at the fact that this is the
pattern and it is a pattern which was
accepted by people was accepted by the
disciples was was accepted by Christ
um and so then when the disciples asked
Christ about this about whether or not
the Elijah will manifest himself before
the Messiah what is the answer that
Christ gives the answer that Christ
gives is the Elijah did Elijah did
manifest himself before the Messiah and
that Elijah was John the Baptist and
Christ even recognizes you know that
this might be slightly difficult for
people to understand how he's joining
those two figures together and so he
says if you're willing to receive it but
nonetheless this is what Christ does you
know Christ shows us how the pattern is
manifesting itself in the world and the
pattern of Elijah coming before Christ
is manifesting itself as st. John the
Baptist manifesting himself before his
own incarnation or coming to announce
his incarnation okay and so that is a
way in which if you look at the actual
let's say events in the world there were
some what messy some what you could say
a bit noisy but Christ was able to see
the pattern which was hidden in in those
in those events and then was able to
point to it and bring out the meaning
the actual spiritual meaning that was in
those those events now here is another
another version which is more related to
to Orthodox tradition an example of what
I call symbolic compression a manner in
which things become compressed together
in a way that is there to show us even
more the pattern even more what the
meaning is behind on event so I want to
show you an image of Pentecost now this
is an icon of Pentecost there are some
variations in the icon of Pentecost but
mostly this is the image which has been
received by the church and if you go to
pretty much any Orthodox Church in the
world that has an image of Pentecost you
will see a variation on this image now
if you look carefully at the image of
Pentecost you will notice that in the
icon of Pentecost there are a few things
happening first of all if you look down
in the bottom of the door there's a
figure sitting there that is holding 12
Scrolls and that figure and he's that
he's sitting in a dark place
now a long time ago when this image
began to develop in the church what used
to be shown in the door which is the
door to outside of the the high place
was a an accumulation of different
groups different races different peoples
that were accumulated in the door this
was of course the show that Pentecost
was the moment where everybody received
the truth of Christ in a manner which
was understandable to them in their own
language so to do that we show these all
these people in the door but some at
some point this these figures all these
figures of different people began to
compress and the compression made it
into this one figure which is named
cosmos and it is in this case we really
do have a a kind of net
for an allegory of cosmos and what it
does is that it it's a it's there to
show you the deeper meaning of the event
which happened in Scripture which is
that it is not only all people but it is
all of creation the entirety of creation
which is to be filled with the Spirit of
God which is filled with the Spirit of
God you know and so you can see the the
the figure of cosmos is holding twelve
Scrolls which are the twelve teachings
let's say of the twelve disciples that
are sitting around around in the upper
room you can see them around but now
let's look at those twelve disciples a
little closer as well if you notice on
the on the on the right side of the icon
and you have to see the right side of
the icon kind of flipped backwards you
have to imagine that that in that empty
space that you see in the middle between
all the different disciples that Christ
would be sitting there this is the empty
seat which is left for Christ in that
empty space so you have to imagine that
if Christ was sitting there to his right
you can see st. Peter with the gray
beard with the curly gray hair and to
his left you can see st. Paul now in the
the description of Pentecost in the
Bible was st. Paul at Pentecost that is
impossible he wasn't even a Christian
that he wasn't even he didn't he had
never heard of Christ he had never heard
of any of this and so in terms of
factuality this is pushing this is
compressing the the this image in a
manner which shows us st. Paul there so
why would you show st. Paul at Pentecost
where we show st. Paul at Pentecost
because we are trying to reveal the
hidden mystery of this story which is a
mystery of the church itself and so st.
Paul is the st. Peter and st. Paul you
could you could call the two pillars of
the church the inner pillar the disciple
the apostle to the Jews and the
outer pillar you could call it the
apostle to the Gentiles those two
notions of the inner and the outer are
there to to to show you that this image
is not just an event in Scripture but is
a an event which is showing us the
pattern of reality itself which is
showing us the left and the right of
Christ which is showing us you know for
people who are interested I've written
several articles about the left and the
right hand of Christ I'll put some links
to that down in the description about
especially st. Peter and st. Paul how
they represent different aspects of the
church and of Christ in the world and so
this is what we're trying to show is how
Christ manifests himself in the world
and is to fill up the entire cosmos now
is this false this is absolutely true
this is what Christians believe this is
what Christians this is a synthesis of
what Christians believe the Holy Spirit
filling the world is and so in order to
do that there is a compression a
symbolic compression which happens which
brings st. Paul into the event which
sometimes also add-in in some of the
icons you'll see for the four
evangelists in the twelve as well and of
course we know that that the evangelists
most of them were not disciples we're
not part of the twelve at least and so
some of them will show the four in that
to once again give us the sense of the
church itself and this pattern is not
only represented in Pentecost but it's
also represented in the Ascension where
we see just like in the other one we see
st. Peter on one side st. Paul on the
other both looking up towards Christ who
is the head and with the mother of God
with Mary in the middle who is the body
and so this image which is an event it
is it is an image of an event in the
Bible but it is compressed in a manner
which is there to show us the hidden and
the deeper meaning of the event and so
one of the problems we have when we're
reading stories in the Bible is that we
are so we are so obsessed with a kind of
forensic manner of describing that we
forget that the purpose of describing
these events is more important than than
just the let's say the randomness of the
or the noisiness of the event itself
there's a reason why those events are
described in the Bible there's a reasons
why the Christians hold those events as
being true and as being foundational for
the church and though and and that
already is a form of symbolic
compression but as you can see in the
image of Pentecost or as you can see in
the way that Christ talks about Saint
John the Baptist and his relation to
Elijah there are ways to cut through the
noisiness
of the world and describe things show
things in a manner which point to their
meaning and to the way in which they
participate in let's say the cosmic
mystery or the cosmic pattern and so now
I know this is really I know I'm pushing
all of you I know that so many of you
will think that I'm again saying that no
everything is relative that no then you
know you can say whatever you want that
is not at all what I'm saying these
patterns are objective these patterns
are you know are objective and so many
of them in their actual let's say
geometric form are universal and so and
and already when you tell a story you
are ignoring a million facts when you
tell the story you are focusing you're
taking all these disparate facts and you
are bringing them together in order to
tell a story now there are ways in which
that can happen even more and these
stories can compress in a manner which
is even tighter and tighter and tighter
and when you look at the if you look at
scripture though the more you go back in
time the more you go back towards
Genesis the more it seems like those
those stories in order to to to describe
more of absolute reality are compressing
things compressing compressing all the
way to the creation narrative which is
which is them that one of the most dense
and complete stories texts that you will
ever read now
do I believe that even even this the
text in Genesis I believe that those are
describing events but they they're not
describing them in a way which would
satisfy the modern historian they're
just not and they don't have to and it
doesn't matter because that's not the
point we don't have those events anymore
the events are gone we all we have are
the stories and so those stories if they
don't reveal to us the the mystery if
they don't reveal to us the higher truth
in a manner in which we can engage with
them then those descriptions are our
futile they're pointless and so I think
that what we need is a shift in our
thinking a very deep shift in our
thinking which is difficult to do but
unless we do that we're not going to
we're not going to get through this
meaning crisis we're not going to get
through even the crisis in Christianity
the the textual crisis with all these
silly Bibles that have you know a
million little pair you know parentheses
and this version of this verse is not in
one of these original texts and and and
this and that and this kind of horrible
textual analysis instead of looking at
the text as something which has been
given to us by the church within a
tradition given to us in order for us to
see those events but see them through
the the lens of their pattern through
the lens of their meaning and how they
are transformative of reality so I hope
this is helpful to you and I know that
even even as you watch this some of you
will find this controversial but it's
important to understand it and it's
important to understand it for all the
videos that I make you know the the when
when I taught when I make a video about
Alex Jones at his description what I'm
looking at is the manner in which the
way he's speaking fits with those
patterns when I talk about a movie I'm
trying to show you the manner in which
the the movie is set up fits with those
patterns and when I talk about scripture
or talk about icons I will do the same
and of course it doesn't mean that I
believe the movie happened and it
doesn't mean that I believe that
Scripture
happen it means that the world is full
of meaning and that the world is glowing
with meaning and and that's what we need
to see if we want to regain our culture
if we want to regain our world if we
want to regain you know our hearts we
need to be able to see that the world is
full of of meaning full of logos and so
all right enough ranting for today I
just want to make a few announcements
before I finish that the dates of my
trip to Paris have changed some people
maybe have seen that I that I put them
up on my website they will be they will
be changing so please check that on the
website if you want to come see me in
Paris the the dates and the event for
the Seattle conference is up I've
already shared it on social media so you
can find that also on my website and for
those that are thought are actually
supporting me on my website financially
I've noticed with the person who is
doing my website I've noticed that some
people have not finished the inscription
process and so because of that you know
some people are not getting
notifications or some people don't have
access to the to the the subscriber only
content and so if you're one of those
people just go on the website there's a
little chat box you can click on the
chat box and and contact them with your
with your issues if you haven't finished
the subscription you can also write me a
note it might you can write me through
the website as well so that we can make
sure that everybody who is is supporting
me has access to the Q&A and also has
access to early access to videos so once
again guys thanks for the support and I
will see you soon